If you've used Claude to write anything
this week, a tweet, a blog, an email,
then it is officially marked. And in
this video, I'm going to explain exactly
what happened, what it means for writing
with AI, and my kind of dark predictions
for what's to come. All right, here's
what happened. So, last week Anthropic
embedded a new kind of watermark inside
of everything that comes out of Claude,
text, design, code, all of it. And so
now everything is secretly marked, and
not the kind of mark that you could just
run through a filter or that you can see
and kind of jumble up the text or edit
or anything like that. I'm talking it is
layered into the code itself, which
means that every platform in the world
will now know exactly when you use
Claude or other AI tools to create
content or not. So, let me give you a
metaphor of what this looks like. Say
you are writing an email that you're
going to put inside of your kit and send
to your email list, which is going to
hit Gmail and Yahoo and Apple Mail and
all those things. You might write an
email and it looks something beautiful
like this, right? Clean, plain text,
very easy to read. But to those
platforms, Kit, Gmail, Yahoo, Apple
Mail, all that stuff, they're going to
see this. And I'll get to why that
matters in just a second, but first you
need to know that this was not something
that Anthropic wanted to do, okay? This
was actually forced upon them by the EU
AI Trademark Transparency Act, which
actually fines them up to $15 million or
3% of global annual revenue, which is a
ton because Anthropic just made $12
billion last quarter. Basically, if they
don't comply, they get fined a big time.
And this is stemming from people are
tired of wondering what's fake and
what's real, and the government is
interceding to say, "Hey, you guys need
to be more transparent and tell us what
is AI and what is human because it is
just getting that indecipherable." But
what matters is what I think will happen
because of this. This is the part I need
you to pay attention to. And I've got
three major predictions. My first one is
that platforms will begin nerfing or
even blocking AI-written content.
Substack is a premium example of this.
They've already started implementing a
tool called Pangram, and with Pangram,
you can actually click people's articles
and posts and things like that, and it
will tell you whether it detects AI
writing or not. Substack has been up in
arms about this. They call it AI shaming
because people are using AI to write
their content, but what it's actually
doing is far beyond that. It's not just
telling you whether AI wrote it. They're
actually algorithmically prioritizing
human-written content. That is a value
of Substack. They want human content to
rise to the surface, which means they're
debuffing AI-written content. So, if you
use AI to write content, it is
deprioritizing your AI-written content
in favor of human-written content. I
think this will take an exponential turn
with all platforms. YouTube's next.
They're already prioritizing
human-written content. They're
deplatforming AI faceless content.
They're actually using, ironically, AI
to scan YouTube scripts just like this
one to see if AI wrote it, and they will
actually debuff and deprioritize
creators who are using AI scripts to
write their content. Next is Twitter,
LinkedIn, all the social platforms. In
fact, I'm making a prediction that very
soon in the near future, there will be a
social media platform that will
completely block any AI content. This is
not even out of that realm as a
prediction. I'm sure somebody is already
making this where if you try to copy and
paste or even use anything out of
Claude, ChatGPT, Gemini, it will be
instantly blocked because of this
watermark. So, this is huge. Even bigger
is for email. How many businesses are
relying upon email revenue for growth,
yet they are using Claude copy, ChatGPT
copy to write these generic sales emails
that, you know, ironically does make
sales for them and so their business is
dependent upon it. They fired their
email marketing manager, they fired
their copywriters, and now I guarantee
you platforms like Gmail and Yahoo and
Apple Mail will begin filtering out any
AI content and putting it way more often
in the spam and the promotions and
eventually maybe even blocking that
style of content. So, this is going to
affect real businesses who are actually
making money with these platforms and
growing on these platforms because
people are tired of the AI slop and the
mediocrity that's hitting all of their
digital mediums. My second prediction is
that people will be falsely accused of
using AI content. For example, this
YouTube video that you are watching,
okay? This is me off the cuff. I don't
fully write the scripts to these videos.
I outline the video and then I do it off
the dome, right? This is me. This is
live. I don't need a script to read off
of. And what I do after this video is I
put it into CapCut to get the transcript
I take that transcript and I put it into
Claude to clean it up and turn it into
an article for me that I post on my
blog. Now, what is going to happen is if
I were to post that article on Substack,
on Twitter, on anything else, that
article is now going to be falsely
identified as AI because I used Claude
to clean it up even though everything I
said in the article is me off my dome
saying it to you in this camera. But,
it's going to have the Claude embed, so
I'm now going to be falsely accused of
using AI to write my content. This is
going to happen all over the place for
people actually writing and just using
AI to edit their content or AI to fix
their English. And so, a lot of people
are actually going to take a hit on this
who have found a ton of value from using
the processes of AI but still thinking
with their own mind, which leads to my
third prediction, which is huge client
risk. If you use Claude to write ads or
emails or content for other clients, it
is going to be easier than ever for them
to be able to identify your content as
AI written. And the first thing that's
going to go through their mind is, why
am I paying this guy two grand, three
grand, five grand a month to just use
Claude to write my stuff? It doesn't
tell them the depth of how much was your
original thinking or Claude's original
thinking or anything like that. All it's
going to do is say, this is AI content.
And it's going to devalue freelancers
all over the place. It's going to get
them fired, which is already happening.
People are already getting fired left
and right for using AI to write the
content. You could go on Upwork right
now and see all of the job posts that
talk about like, can't use AI to write
this. No AI copywriting. Must be human
written because people are craving the
voice, the tone, and the originality of
humans. But ironically, those are the
same schlubbs that are paying five bucks
an hour who want, you know, the world.
But either way, those things are
happening. People will lose jobs because
they're going to be flagged
significantly more easier for using AI
because of this watermark. On the flip
side, there is a huge opportunity that I
want to make sure you know. And that is
that original thinkers and writers are
about to get more leads, sales,
subscribers, and cash than anybody else
because they are going to be promoted
more. Clients are going to need
copywriters who can sell without Claude.
Creators will need people who could
teach without a script. And every
platform is going to begin rewarding the
human voice, original thinking way
beyond the AI copy and paste content
slot that you see today. And so, the
need for original content is going to
skyrocket because think about it, these
platforms are dependent on dwell time.
Dwell time is the amount of time that
people spend on platforms. And what they
are noticing is that people are spending
less and less time reading Twitter and
LinkedIn and things like that because
all of it is the same slop over and over
and over again. And so, they're going to
start populating the things that people
do read, the things that people do
interact with, which is ding ding ding
original thinking and original writing.
So, the value of copywriting, sales
persuasion, all that stuff, actually
knowing it from your heart and not
having to depend on a prompt is going to
go to the moon for everybody who gets
this. And so, here's what I would
recommend that you do immediately.
First, you need to start mastering
copywriting. Even if you know the
fundamentals, no matter what, you need
to start doing a deep dive on persuasion
psychology copywriting and selling
immediately. This needs to get into your
head without having to prompt anything.
And second, you need to start building
your own email list, so that way you are
not dependent on clients or bipolar
algorithms. You need to have an email
list that you can own, that you can
write to, that you can reach out to, and
build a relationship with, so that you
could sell your own stuff apart from
clients falsely accusing you of doing
this or doing that. I'm telling you the
client world is becoming more and more
volatile. Unless, of course, you're
original writer, you have a track record
of that, and you can provide proof of
sales. And so, here are a couple
resources to help you do that. One, if
you want to learn how to build a
clientless business by writing emails,
then I left a link in the description
below for my school community, Copy
Creator Club. You could go check that
out. My personal coaching and mentorship
is in there alongside hundreds of hours
of resources to help you do that. But
two, if you want to get a free resource
on how to master copywriting, then here
is a video right now on the screen that
you can click and watch a complete
copywriting masterclass from myself on
how to do that. But before you click
over to that video, I want to hear your
thoughts. Leave a comment down below.
What do you think about this cloud
watermark? What do you think is going to
happen in the future? What are your
predictions based on everything that I
said in the video? Drop a comment down
below. Let me know what you think, and I
will catch you on the next one. I hope
you enjoy the masterclass.